for some time now and even today and
beyond I have been living in a sober
house I am driven by my 24 hour sober
coach back to a home lights out by 10
p.m. so I go to my room and they stare
at the ceiling and I fall asleep to wake
up to come back here to see you so that
is my truth Wendy was in tears sharing
her truth this morning but is the
talk-show host telling the whole story
earlier this month Wendy returned to her
daytime talk show telling viewers she
took two months off to deal with health
issues caused by Graves disease but some
say that's not the full story today the
Daily Mail is reporting that Wendy was
actually at a drug and alcohol rehab in
Florida during that time for the timing
of Wendy's announcement et has learned
the Daily Mail TV had been investigating
Wendy's two-month absence and had asked
her to comment on their report she
instead chose to go public because a
source tells us she wanted it to be her
story to tell Wendy was candid with et
about how she struggled with addiction
in the 90s I lost over a decade of my
life being hooked on cocaine Wendy says
back then she was able to turn her life
around without rehab
I don't know how except God was sitting
on my shoulder and I just stopped Wendy
made headlines when she collapsed on
live TV in 2017 she attributed the fall
to her Graves disease when she sat down
with us last July Wendy had this message
for people struggling with addiction you
got to get yourself together life is
sweet on the other side you want this
[Music]